this was an unexpected surprise
thank you guys
for a full hour it's so awesome to meet
you
keep doing what you do guys we keep
watching
you guys give me nipple chills man that
was amazing
[Music]
[ __ ] you guys are being real i thought
you were mocking us
big fans like
we have questions for you
oh man
you've got six minutes with us buddy
for a major loop oh goodness
we're blushing
thanks good has this begun
oh it's good it's been a whirlwind of a
day so you've put us oh thank you much
easier that was so surprising holy [ __ ]
um
all right well i mean this is great
because uh i wanted to mention that you
guys directed bad boys for life and we
said this when we first talked about it
that that is our favorite bad boys movie
easily so
thank you appreciate it you you did the
input we will not ask you about the will
smith slap even though that will get us
the wisdom
did
[Laughter]
um we wanted to ask though like with
with the background you guys have with
filmmaking what marvel character would
you like to see receive the r-rated
treatment and what would you do like as
as we discussed this family-friendly
miss marvel show like what
what will be the r-rated marvel movie
you would want to make oh oh i mean
obviously you know deadpool and blade
has already have already been made in in
our rated version but uh yeah i mean i
mean i was so scared of the hulk when i
was a kid you know when i watched like
the original tv show yes and and and i
think that you know r-rated hulk
scary scary and next level i see yeah i
love that idea i've always wanted to see
a r-rated uh hulk versus wolverine movie
that's oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
bloody bloody yeah exactly
and i mean then you know kind of
speaking about the the kind of
differences and tones you guys are also
doing you know you got batgirl going
while you also have miss marvel going
you know what were the sort of key
differences in inhabiting two worlds
with very different tones and one that
does appeal more broadly versus one that
has more of a dark aesthetic well yeah
it was it was great to have that
spectrum you know and a great honor to
be able to work in both worlds you know
where miss marvel is really that that
you know
applies to a young garages you would say
it's vibrant it's hopeful it's colorful
you have that animation well batgirl is
in a darker world it's dc it's gotham
city it's uh it's batman and and it's
more inspired by you know like the bad
girl we grew up with in the animated
series so so you have both spectrum you
have a lot of similarities of course but
one is more adult darker and the other
is colorful and teenager
that's a really solid answer right there
you guys seem to have like a knack for
mixing like a bunch of stylish action
with cultural stories so what was most
important for you guys to communicate
with for your own cultural perspective
would you say and what was the biggest
adjustment when we were editing bad boys
for life we were thinking uh what's the
next step and we were thinking it has to
be you know marvel is the biggest and
the biz
[Laughter]
speaking into existence man yeah
and they were like joking yeah he has to
be a muslim character because we never
saw that and then not knowing that it
existed uh and then yeah then we
discovered miss marvel
and just uh fell in love with kamala
khan and world and family and really we
had that real personal connection
because you know we're moroccan belgians
that we're between the moroccan culture
and the belgian culture similarly like
kamala khan is between american culture
and the pakistani muslim culture we are
muslims ourselves so we had this yeah
this deep connection with this story and
then she's also a teenager trying to
find the world the identity crisis that
we have when we were young you know also
trying to be cool but clumsy and you
know like
like totally
in our own world and fantasies i was
also doodling all day yeah yeah yeah
so yeah all of that you know i was like
yeah this is like a very special story
that needs to be told to the world and
and
super happy we could make this i love
that you said that because you know this
is a story about like a teenage girl
like hear like men talking about it
because that was something like i'm i'm
not i'm filipino uh first generation so
in america and so i i related to it so
much and i wasn't expecting to relate so
much to it and to hear how you guys
related to it i think that's one of the
most surprising things about this show
is it's actually very very relatable for
a lot of people more than they're
probably anticipating man exactly it's
universal story that's always the goal
yeah yeah amen well dude uh this was an
unexpected surprise
thank you guys
for a full hour it's so awesome
what you do guys we keep watching
you guys give me nipple chills man that
was amazing
[Laughter]
hi my name is greg alba and i'm john
humphrey and we are with the real
rejects um hi mira thanks for talking
with us today uh this show was a an
absolute delight it was so so fun and
it's so feel good absolutely uh
feel good in a world that doesn't feel
so good yeah that's why i felt like it's
kind of a necessary experience in a lot
of ways
i just found it incredibly charming i
wanted to ask my i was speaking with a
friend of mine um named rashad a few
weeks ago and i asked him about like
what was his experience like when he
first discovered miss marvel and he said
it was so impactful he grew up on the
comics so i'm curious
what was your emotional reaction or
experience when you first discovered the
character or the comic of miss marvel
similarly uh similarly i felt like
pretty emotional but i was just excited
like i was gifted the comic by a friend
of mine and she was like
look at this cover and i looked at it
and it's like a brown girl wearing a
scarf and bangles and
says no normal right and i was like this
is very strange because that feels very
familiar all of those things yeah yeah
and then i read it and she's from jersey
city and she's got this like green
beanie on an army jacket and just like
everything about her felt so familiar
to me i mean i grew up in jersey as well
but beyond just the journey i almost
feel like the jersey thing is the thing
i love about kamala more so than the
brown girl
because it's so specific to who she is
you know she's just this girl on the
other side of the hudson river that
wants to be a part of the action but i
do think for the south asian community i
mean i'm indian i'm not pakistani so i
definitely felt very deferential towards
the pakistani muslim experience that was
being represented on the show and
wanting to
make sure that
i was listening to all the voices around
me to
to make sure that we were doing our
small part of it right the kid of
immigrants first generation kid just
feeling like your parents want one thing
and you want something else for your
life what she was going through is such
a familiar story for anyone with that
first generation experience that was
meaningful it's very meaningful to see
that be such a successful and impactful
part of pop culture and now it's going
to be that much more it's kind of wild
absolutely i mean i'm i'm not in here
pakistani i'm first generation my mom's
filipino first generation here in
america so yeah there's a lot i was like
oh wow i might not be a teenage girl but
i really understand a lot of this
experience so yeah yeah yeah absolutely
john yeah and i mean
two looking at these first couple of
episodes that we've seen as of now
talking to you you know one thing that
seemed pretty remarkable is you know
between bilal in a deal and then your
you know direction there's a remarkable
amount of fluidity and consistency
across all that even though the show has
such a unique and very it feels like one
of the most cinematic mcu entries thus
far to me so basically what did you guys
do to communicate in order to create
that consistency of tone yeah it was
hard because we were doing them like
almost simultaneously like just back to
back with one another you know we were
often shooting things on the same days
you know adeel and bilal were so clear
about what mattered to them and i felt
like i was really clear about what
mattered to me and i think that and
charmaine was really clear about what
what matters to her like i think the
fact that like all of that came together
is a testament to you know the way in
the way that marvel kind of cast us as
directors you know we all we all come
from such different experiences but i
think that the hybrid quality of that is
what makes the show feel
like a lot of different things
yeah what one one of our favorite things
about this
when watching it was just even though
it's not a show full of superheroes at
least right now there's not a show full
of superheroes was that the family
dynamics and the friendship dynamics
felt so
natural it felt so sincere and real so
i'm kind of curious what was the
preparation like from the directing
standpoint behind the scenes before
filming of getting these actors ready to
do these scenes because it's so it's
incredibly natural they feel like a real
family especially yeah i mean that's the
kind of stuff that was really important
to me so i'm glad that felt that way to
you they were so new to each other even
doing episode two they had only been
filming with each other for
like a week or two at that point so it
was still all very new
so i mean some of the things we did on
our episodes well one of the things i
did with um iman and matt the first time
i met them they were like do you want to
do a rehearsal with iman and matt and i
was like sure
and our rehearsal was just playing
settlers of katan together we just like
sat down
we sat in a big stage and just played
katan together for like
an hour and a half two hours
i hadn't played it actually in a really
long time so i kind of forgot some of
the rules and i remember at one point i
did something wrong i put a bridge where
i wasn't supposed to bridge and iman was
like you can't do that and i remember
thinking this girl's awesome she's gonna
like when i do something that she
doesn't agree with she's gonna let me
know and i think that's so important for
actors to feel comfortable enough to
voice
when they think something isn't right
and so for me i just tried to create
that environment on set every day as
well for the actors
when we'd rehearse i'd want to make it
to feel very loose i'd often ask them to
improvise the beginning of the scene and
the end of the scene just to give them
help them give themselves away into the
scene and out of the scene but like
obviously shoot the script as
you know for
as written for the bulk of it but just
give them some loose ends to play with
so that they could just you know kind of
find a way to settle into it and feel
comfy with each other and then i'll say
it was complete the actors 90 of the
work was done on their own just they
knew that they had they also were just
in atlanta together and had no one else
to hang out with but they were hanging
out with each other a lot and becoming
real friends and that helps that helps a
lot um we didn't have to deal with any
drama and make it feel like forced once
it was on set they genuinely like each
other and i think it really it really
shows yeah it doesn't feel like it's
manipulated by editing i'm like these
guys seem like they really got a longer
yeah and even the inclusion of bruno
within that is sort of the outsider
accepted into the family like it all
feels really really natural yeah what we
want to do is review the episode for you
right now yeah
i do i approve of this yes i like i like
all the things you're taking away from
me
it makes me feel very optimistic
people will watch this show
well thank you so much ramira for your
time i know you got other bunch of other
people to talk to as well so thank you
so much and i'm excited for people to
watch miss marvel thank you guys thanks
for your questions they were really
lovely thank you thank you